they are spontaneous gatherings that
have become well-known residents of
royal woods and bassets lining the
streets to pay tribute to the fallen
when raf lyneham closes coffins arriving
at aria brize norton will travel a
different routes bypassing the nearby
town of carterton there are fears this
is repatriation through the back door we
discussed it with all of the agencies
the police were sought to achieve
District Council the Parish Council and
the time council and it was determined
that that was the best route the coroner
was keen to speed to get the court age
22 the junior so that the course mortem
could be carried out and he could
release the bodies to the relatives the
same day is hopes the new routes will
provide minimal disruption sue carterton
a town that shares similarities with
royal wootton bassett residents here
believe spontaneous gatherings will be
harder to achieve the cortege should
pass through the town centre I don't
think it's a good idea at all because
it's out the way they've gone up there
to fight for us and they've given their
life for us and they're being shoved out
the back you just taken to hospital it's
going to be distressing they've got your
kids then you can avoid the area but say
it's a military town you know we're all
here to support each other so we should
be given that opportunity to do so
people like to think our horses are
doing a very good job you know it's nice
to welcome the moment like that since
2007 royal Wootton Bassett has become
synonymous with the war in Afghanistan
crowds have gathered in silent tribute
as each flag-draped coffins made its
weight of the coroner the new routes
will see each hairs travel through this
gates along speed bumps and a rose for
those and Wheaton Bassett this is
difficult to swallow I know the area I
think it's a bad place to take them they
could have let them in what Bassett
blowing them they can't fulfill what
wouldn't masses gun they wouldn't
Bassett turned out in block were there
any thought of themselves or any of they
just turn up with our coffee gone
through this street they're about to
everyone re etheline and wore clothes in
September an end of an era for weeds and
Bassett's and memorial garden will be
built along the new roots in the hope
local residents were brought there to
say goodbye Kumar fam bellaire Sky News